here is a question I just want to pull
it before we even see the question
because what are that to do is iostream
hustling but as I try to do all the time
right I want to do more than just show
you how to get the answer right because
as you will see shortly like their
amount of working for this is not
incredible right but more importantly
you're not a working that goes into this
just things that are very very simple
like stuff you learn in your 8 year 10
early you 10 it's not it's not
groundbreaking stuff so why is it that
we 12 MTX one even why are we having
trouble with this question okay because
honestly like I think if I can't have
trouble quickly describe the question is
why right let's have a look and unpack
it they say you've got a right angle
triangle and it sides a B and C Graham
breaking so far I know okay now they
then say a couple of things about B
right - like imaginary situations and
then they ask you to find this this is
the actual question find this right here
okay now for starters let me give you a
suggestion as to why this is a weird
question you don't even know it stop how
it was a last time you got us to find a
ratio right we get us to find a value
sold for this or add up whatever right
all a hundred fours well you know that
kind of thing whereas this it's just
phrased in a weird way okay
now don't forget a ratio rational
numbers right therefore all it really
wants is this fraction you can write
that fraction that you're done that's
what the ratio is
okay it's the first thing secondly
usually in a right-angled triangle we
know you know sees the hypotenuse
usually doesn't matter which one a and
which one is a and which one is B in my
diagram at least so and almost every
single one of the ones that I've seen it
does matter which one it's a and B which
one has to be big I've got two scenarios
that being could be was the am ones the
GM right
in either case are you satisfied that V
is going to be between a and C do you
agree with that sees the longest side in
the Tri
therefore a has to be the shortest one
right you had the shortest then the
intermediately and then on this one not
better matters just in the side you just
have some weird diagrams if your
arithmetic mean is somehow smaller than
okay so these are not my scenarios let's
start with what were you know the easy
stuff which is I know what one question
time I know what the am of a and C is
okay so let's just start off I'm going
to say B equals the arithmetic mean is
just what we used to think of as the the
average between these two numbers okay
so I'm going to add them together and
then I'm going to half then the question
becomes well what on earth do I do with
that okay where do I go from here okay
now remember this is what I am trying to
get to there's my endpoint as it were
right if this is what I want and this is
what I know
then this clearly implies some kind of
relationship like this is equal to some
number let's just make up something like
under two over no I know something like
that okay so this isn't the answer by
the way but if this were the answer what
this implies is that I can write a or C
right either one of those as a function
of the other one right for instance in
this case I could say C equals 2 over 9
a right like that would be that line
would proceed this line okay and then
I'll just divide by am well your uncle
this your wish here okay so I don't 1 in
terms of the other and I want to get its
mom actually your uncle sorry if that's
the case okay so if you're if you're a
Bob and you're like an uncle you've got
nephews or nieces
you must be separated anyway okay so
therefore now I decide to become clear
how I'm going to use this right because
I know it's a right angle triangle
that's bad I know so therefore I'm gonna
say the thing that I know about all
right angle triangles namely Pythagoras
is here okay now in Scenario question a
I don't need to write B anymore I'm
gonna replace it with this okay so
Pythagoras theorem for this triangle
states this do you agree with that
that's just what Pythagoras looks like
in this case
okay now this is what a lot this is my
relationship between a and C admittedly
it's a bit messy in there like it's
intertwined in that kind of thing
particularly this guy okay but that's
alright I work with these kinds of
things all the time right
all I want is a equals
something-something C or vice-versa C
equals something-something a so how do I
tease it out what kind of equation is
this what much family of equations does
it belong to
it's a quadratic isn't it okay now I can
solve quadratics I've been solving
quadratics in house come hard house what
kind of format do I want this quadrant
to be in so I can solve it easily one in
general form okay so let's make it in
general form I'm gonna have to get
everything on the left hand side and
then we'll equal 0 right so let's just
unpack it first I want to get rid of the
fractions because general tends not to
have fractions in it so what shall I
bolts play everything my for for cuz
it's actually two square done it writes
it is there's a trick which all right so
that gives me this okay I've just
multiplied through and now I just want
to get everything on one side right so
let's see I'm going to expand on the
left-hand side which gives me this and I
have this on the right-hand side okay I
could combine them some Y terms there
right how many a squares do I have five
of them how many see squids do I have a
red runner on the Left I have negative
three of them minus 3 C squared are you
ok with that
okay now this reads out our brains a
little bit okay because it's quadratic
but as it happens it's a quadratic in a
it's also a quadratic in C right a brain
is not used to seeing quadratics that
have two things in them okay but don't
forget all of these things they just
numbers they're just not it if I said C
we're equal to like five right this
would be 5 a squared plus 10 a minus 75
okay so it would just be another number
okay now that's what it would be
sequence with equals 5 the pulp our
boundaries I can work with it when I
one sees equals okay so let me just make
this a little more obvious I want this
in general form right I've already got
an a squared term out the front so I
might as well make that my quadrant so
I'm gonna go 5a squared she's gonna
rewrite this as plus this that what was
the point of doing that that's the point
of writing it in that form okay it's
because I want an a squared term an
eight and I want to constant term you
okay with that there's my clinton desert
it's already seen it okay now i've
written it as a quadratic what's the
point of writing things sorry as a
general quadratic what's the point of
writing in such form it's so i could do
one of two things
I can either factorize it right or if
I'm too lazy to factorize I can just
chuck it into the formula do you guys
want to factor was it is it hard to
factorize let's think I want to para
from this your braids weenie a little
because they're pretty was in it we can
do this right I want a pair of numbers
what does the pair of numbers add 2 to 2
I think it's to C right
see it's just another number I don't
know what it is but it's there in the
coefficient isn't it okay that's my as
the reason why I put the brackets around
it to try and make that a little more
obvious so I got genomes that add 2 to
see what do the numbers multiply to
negative 5 times -3 squared that's
negative 15 C squared
something times something equals
negative 15
C squared okay now just hold on for a
second to finish sorry can you be
treated why
alpha beta is - you're thinking about
you're just thinking about the roots I'm
think about factorizing roots come off I
factorize solutions come after factoids
okay so just like just like when you're
thinking of this you're going a step
forward so my favorite for daddy
the the numbers the factorize out of two
and three but the answers the roots what
your people are negative to a negative 3
right I see you gonna step in what am i
pair of numbers guys it would be easy if
you didn't have seen right clearly it's
going to be 5 and negative 3
do you agree with that or rather 5 seats
and minus 3 C okay so I would give 5 C
minus 3 C that works out 5 c minus 3 C
okay sir now it brick-anew punch it
what was I supposed to do with those
what about what am I gonna do them now
they've got them I can I can put them
into here no right I can write this in a
fold over easy for me so if I write
write 5 a squared
let's see I'll put 5 C at the front then
I go minus 3 C minus 3 C squared
yeah you okay with that what am I doing
here
this is one way of my many that I can
factorize it's the whole point of coming
up with this pair of numbers right
because now I don't have a trinomial so
I've got a terms right where where which
one is oh yeah sorry
that's right that's not there okay so
now I've got my four terms and I can
pair them up right what's my um my
factor out here finding 5a outside of a
yeah
it works yeah you okay with that so now
I've got this guy five a take three see
a plus C equals zero okay so I factorize
and now I can read some solutions of
this right
I can sulfa seorak and sulfur I don't
really matter okay if I let this equal
zero this guy over here what solution do
I get out of that for a - that'd be bad
yes oh it's all right to me yeah I'll
leave that for a second I'll come back
to it I get a solution on this but I'll
see the solution of this right what
solution do I get out of this okay
now I'm not done yet right I'm not done
yet okay you can't just pretend
solutions don't exist okay I have two
solutions out of here I have to
disregard one and I have to disregard
for a reason I can disregard this one
why because because because but ANSI
have to be positive right and the only
way to make this true is if one of them
is negative okay Serg so therefore but a
nice reading zero C is greater than zero
so that's not a real solution out of
here now I can get to my answer which
was C - a is the same as C divided by a
right so I'll divide by C which gives me
this and then I'll take the reciprocal
which gives me this so my ratio is 5 to
3 now are you happy with that okay now
just let me make a note because I want
to say something a bit similar if you if
you went the quadratic formula route
from from here right from here
everything would be exactly the same and
you just end here right but there's a
slight in any way you can say you can
save yourself a bit
time okay I I just because I was lazy I
ended up doing that so I got out from
there after after some number of lines I
said a was equal to now I get my plus or
minus line like this this is what ends
up falling out okay now just let you
look at this for a second you can see
where am i - to see you comes from right
and then there's my discriminant and so
on okay now this second at this second
before I even get to this equals
something right
I can already discount a solution can
you see what because a is equal to one
of two things but one of the solutions
is ridiculous I didn't even need to
evaluate it right because if you've got
a negative number and then you subtract
something you're gonna get even more
negative of course we know it's gonna
end up here but you don't even need to
know that it's gonna end up there and
this one here I can say but it's
positive right
therefore it's got to be if where it
must be this case I can ignore the other
case without even evaluating you okay so
sometimes you will have to do that like
as in you have to get to you I go to
factorize okay so therefore you might as
well know that this trick exists if you
want something positive you gave know
something that will clearly give you a
negative without evaluating it okay